- I'm all about serving up the best
of the interwebs that will make you smile.
This is, "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applause)
And this one starts, innocently enough.
A nun named, Sister Monica Clare,
posted to her four subscribers, on TikTok,
about a wild Turkey,
terrorizing the property,
outside the convent.
(swooshing)
- Okay, so we have this wild turkey,
who's been terrorizing all of
the sisters in the convent.
(Monica laughs)
And basically, eating
all our outdoor plants
and scratching up cars and
running off all the birds
and the chipmunks and squirrels.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- What is wrong with that turkey?
As you can imagine, Sister Monica Clare,
didn't expect much fanfare from the post,
but in just days, the TikTok racked in
hundreds of thousands of views, why?
Well, she titled her post,
"Update on the Wild Turkey Situation".
(audience and Kelly laugh)
Which is awesome because she's a nun.
(audience laughs)
Oh, so great.
Oh, yeah, people clicked
thinking they might see
a nun, slugging back some whiskey,
because that's who we are
as a nation, apparently.
But there's more, the
viewers started engaging
with her about the most
unexpected thing, her skin.
We have Sister Monica Clare,
on the line to explain.
Hey, Sister.
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Kelly.
Thank you so much for
having me on your show.
- No, thank you so much
for coming on our show,
we love you, we are big fans.
So, what did you think,
when you started getting all the views?
- I was completely shocked,
because at the time, I
literally had four followers
and I was just trying to
make those four people laugh,
whether this antics of this crazy, turkey,
who had no boundaries, apparently.
(audience laughs)
So, then I started posting
informational videos,
after the turkey videos started to pick up
and all these women started following me,
all these gen-X women,
with kind of, the same dry
sense of humor that I have.
And they started messaging me about,
because I had said that I was 55 years old
and they said, "How
could he be 55 years old?
Tell us what you do for
your skincare routine".
And at first, I ignored
it because I'm a nun,
I'm not supposed to focus on like,
skincare and beauty things.
(Monica and Kelly laugh)
So, basically I just ignored it
and it just got completely out of hand,
because every video I
posted people were like,
"Girl, drop your skincare routine".
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I love where this
started and where it ended.
(audience cheers)
It started from a wild, turkey,
to people being curious about a drunk nun
and then it ended up with skincare.
It's amazing, actually.
- Actually, crazy.
And then I got to meet
you, which is wonderful.
(audience cheers)
- Well, it's an honor to meet you as well.
Thank you for joining
us, Sister Monica Clare.
I'm liking your posts right now.
(bell dings)
- [Monica] Thank you.
- Well, that's not all,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
thinks that your TikToks
are fantastic, as we do.
So, in recognition,
they'll be using their,
G2 gelling pen to write you a
check for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- [Monica] That's so sweet, thank you.
- Absolutely.